and talk about shock and all when it  comes to witnessed a scene one of these  airplanes overhead whether it be an  airshow or during training practice some  where the noise and is absolutely  incredible so one wonders if you're on  the ground there and one of these things  are coming at you even before they drop  their payload  unfortunately I mean they're not pet  plane from the cameras if we can talk  about the noise which they can stack it  right vertically upwards and when they  do that in really noise and they can do  that against the typhoons to explain the  difference between the typhoons and the  tornados the typhoons are a much newer  aircraft and they were designed  originally as an air superiority  superiority aircraft so dogfights  protecting the skies of the UK taking on  other aircraft up in the sky the